meeting please you have the
floor excuse
me Mr President might I ask you to spare
a thought for the terrorist attack in
Brussels last night where two Swedish
citizens were murdered I'd be grateful
if we could Mark that with a minute
silence this morning thank
you I
know when the president will have the
floor
will have a minute of Silence thank you
very much for your comment obviously our
condolences are with the vict victims of
the
attack presidency of the council you
have the
floor thank you president honorable
members
commissioner Russia's war of aggression
against Ukraine is a clear violation of
the UN chter and the fundamental
principles of international law thanks
to our Unity we've managed to provide
political economic and Military Support
to Ukraine and adopt an unprecedented
range of sanctions against the Russian
regime the current sanctions regime
against Russia is the widest and most
decisive ever decided upon by the
European Union
as expressed by our leaders at the
versai summit last year the European
Union is prepared to step up pressure on
Russia and
belus including the adoption of further
restrictive measures our sanctions have
been designed to reduce Russia's
capacity to carry out its illegal war
against Ukraine reduce it State's budget
and prevent access to key Technologies
which are relevant to defense the
effectiveness of this system has been
shown by the decline of the defense and
Manufacturing Industries in Russia and
its lost of competitiveness over the
medium and longer term but we need to
enforce new sanctions to step up the
effectiveness of our
regime the recent measures adopted in
the 11
sanctions package have this goal in mind
this is important for all the the
assets sanctioned but also
for combat technologies that uh Russia
would be able to purchase to pursue its
war against Ukraine given the
significance of the measures it's
important they be uniformly enforced
that means we have to start by preaching
by example the European Union must
redouble its efforts for
cooperation thanks to cooperation
amongst the member states and the
commission thank
you thank you very much now for the
commissioner commission Mr
Rees thank you president dear state
Secretary dear members of the parliament
uh today we Face a grim Milestones it is
600 days since Russia's war of
aggression began against Ukraine since
day one we have been clear where we
stand we stand with Ukraine for as long
as it takes And We Stand United as a
European Union together we have adopted
11 package of sanctions so far together
we have act to end our energy Reliance
on Russia within a very short space of
time and together we have successfully
Diversified our supplies of energy and
raw
materials let me now briefly outline the
impact of our measures on Russia first
of all I want to reassure you sanctions
are having a strong impact on the
Russian economy not that Russia
carefully share picks the economic data
that it publishes sanctions have curbed
the revenues that Russia can use to
finance the war for instance budget
figures reveal that Russia's income from
order and gas has significantly declined
while there are large increases in
military
spending this has result in an estimate
budget deficit of 1.7 trillion rubbles
in fact 15.9 billion EUR for this year
we can see that the old price Gap and
sanctions more generally are depriving
Russia of its usual income sources to
finance the war in addition immobilizing
the assets of the Central Bank of Russia
of about 300 billion Euro of which 2/3
we know are in the European Union was
effective it immediately created strong
pressure on the rubel and forced the
Russian authorities to turn to drastic
Capital control
measures and it is important to
recognize that Russia is implementing a
number of measures to support its
economy and counter the effects of
sanctions while these Russian counter
measures May provide some
stabilization they also tie up resources
that would otherwise be available to
finance the war the Russian cont
measures also include the illegal
expropriation of foreign assets and
forced administration of foreign
companies which undermine prospects for
return to
normality Russia is going now through a
so-called reconstruction process
allegedly rebuilding its economy and
reorienting its trade flows but the
outcome of this process is a less
efficient economy facing higher costs
first and foremost Russia's War and the
strong response from the European Union
and our allies compromise the grow
potential of the Russian economy
inflationary expectations are increasing
again Russia Central Bank is puring a
more restrictive policy and their fiscal
space is not large enough to extend
sufficient support to all
sectors Russia's long-term growth is
undermined by our sanctions regime to
and let us not forget the kind of growth
Russia is experiencing at the moment
Russia is turning its economy into a war
economy but manufacturing weapons and am
min itions will not improve the
well-being of Russian
citizens there is no room for
complacency sanctions need to be
implemented in full we are working
closely with the member states
likeminded partners and third countries
to tackle gaps and to address Russia's
attempts to circumvent or restrictive
measures in fact we are doing the same
with Russia as a country that what we
try to do with the oligarchs and
entities on the list of sanction where
we are trying to freeze the assets of
those oligarchs and entities and you
know that we are in discussion with you
and with the council about a proposal of
directive to harmonize the different
sanctions and the definition of
sanctions when there is an attempt to
circumin the sanction regime and
certainly when there is an attempt to
circumin such possibility to freeze
assets we want to go to a step further
Injustice with a possible confiscation
of such a kind of assets so we are
working on that and we have had again a
meeting of the task force with all the
member states uh yesterday uh in in
Brussels about about that and I said so
we are working very closely with the
member states and Russia is building new
physical and financial infrastructure
and restructuring trade patterns
Logistics and Supply chains to cvent all
sanctions these C convention effort
showed that sanctions are working as
intended and cutting of access to many
Goods of course sanctions cannot win the
war alone and there will always be
profits looking to make a quick book
however they can including by evading
sanctions these sanctions damage our
Collective
efforts and all these actions sorry
damage or or Collective efforts all the
actions to try to cumene the sanctions
or to take profits in the uh framework
of the sanctions and we need to work
closely again with our partners to
prevent circumvention we need all member
states to play their part and the
commission will continue to support them
for example our sanction now allow us to
list people who facilitate the evasion
of sanctions the commission is Con
continually revising his guidance and
facts and the commission regularly
convenes meeting with member state to
discuss implementation and to exchange
best practices we also need to act with
our International Partners this is why
we have appointed an au International
special Envoy for sanctions
implementation the envoy's work has
focused on stopping Russia's attempts to
procure key Technologies for the
battlefield prohibited by our sanctions
that that make their way to Russia via
third country we are also in regular
contact with third countries to learn
together how to best limit sanctions
circumvention honorable members thank
you for the opportunity to speak to you
today because it's not enough to put
into place 11 package of sanctions the
most important part is to be sure that
it's possible to enforce those sanctions
and again to fight against all form of
of s conventions and I'm count on your
support to continue to work on this
sometimes and so with some legislative
proposals uh of course I know that you
are sharing the commission's commitment
towards Ukraine and I thank you for it
so we continue to work together and I
will be very pleased to hear your views
today thank
you thank you thank you very much to
both speakers for their introductory
remarks now the floor goes to Andreas
kilius dear
colleagues the fact is that Russia still
is able to continue and to finance its
war against
Ukraine Russia recently announced that
in 2024 its defense budget will be
increased by nearly 70% and will reach
107 billion EUR from the very beginning
of the war we introduced sanctions on
Russian oil and gas exports as a major
source of Russian Financial income first
of all of course we need to see that
those sanctions are working Russia gets
two times less income from export of gas
and oil than they were receiving before
the war the most painful sanctions were
established last December with with the
introduction of oil price cap since the
oil bring is bringing the biggest amount
of income despite the fact that the
price cap sanctions hit Russian income
very heavily still Russia is able to get
around of 700 million EUR a day from its
fossil fuel exports and EU is still
sending to Russia around of2 billion EUR
per month for the import of oil and gas
it's time for us to look how we can
increase effectiveness of our sanctions
policy especially on gas and oil I would
like just to name next steps what we
need to do first to further lower the
cap on crude oil price from the current
$60 per barrel to $3 us per barrel
second to impose an embargo on Russian
LNG Imports said to introduce
restriction on fuel Imports if fuels are
produced by set countries using Russian
oil fourth to introduce price cap on
Russian ammonium fertilizer
exports fifth to prohibit trans shipment
of Russian oil and LG through EU
territorial Waters and exclusive
economic zones six to introduce
restrictions on European tanker services
on sale of of tankers as well as on
European insurance services for tankers
if this are used to export Russian oil
and seventh to introduce a reinforced
and centralized U level oversight of
sanctions implementation in addition
let's introduce sanctions on companies
which are building Russian Arctic to LNG
terminal let's introduce sanctions on
export of Russian aluminum and on
rosatom and export of nuclear fuel it
depends on us if Russia will continue to
be able to finance its
War thank you very much the next speaker
is Mr
chich dear president dear commissioner
the sanctions were intended to lower
Russia's capacity to continue the war of
aggression have we succeeded to a
limited extent unfortunately the budget
Revenue is smaller it's harder to
produce ammunition and military
equipment but the war is continuing in
some cases paradoxically the sanctions
were
counterproductive freezing the assets of
some oligarch meant that 50 billion Euro
came back to Russia we all know what is
happening Russia is reorganizing its
economy some countries do not recognize
our sanctions India and China have
leaped up on this uh occasion in order
to earn more money technological
sanctions are also bypassed via European
companies many of our companies do
business as usual yes uh the Imports of
gas and oil to Europe have been called
ciled but they continue does this all
mean that the sanctions should be
abolished of course not they should be
continued we need to be consistent our
reliability is at stake however we need
to be even more determined and speak
with one voice we did introduce some
exceptions and derogations but they
cannot be forever we should think uh
about secondary sanctions to be imposed
on on those countries that are not
helping with our efforts the war is on
our border supporting the aggressor May
mean that we are careless about our own
security it is also urgent to use this
most powerful weapon I.E freezing and
confiscating the frozen assets of
Russian money abroad it's not true that
it would be illegal it can be done
legally the commission is wrong here
both politically and legally this money
should go to
Ukraine helping the victim is a way to
weaken the aggressor what thank you the
next speaker is Mr Bernarda yes
you
colleagues let's State the
obvious no economic sanction against any
regime has ever brought an economy to
its knees and this is true of Russia
today as it was of South Africa but
International sanctions are nevertheless
a formidable weapon because they stifle
industry they exacerbate Financial
difficult ulties and they force that the
target to constantly find ways around
them and this is the case of uh Putin's
Russia and for this reason it's absurd
totally absurd to talk about ineffective
blows to uh to putinism putinism is hurt
by these sanctions and is suffering
because of them but obviously there are
some loopholes in our measures we need
to take new measures that are more
targeted and which hurt the aggressor
even more we need to uh St take stock of
what has worked well or worked less well
or not worked whatsoever and this is
what our Parliament will do next month
by calling on the council and the
commission to do even better even more
and even faster because the end of this
war depends on that thank you thank you
very much Mr lagodinsky you have the
floor effectiveness of San
is determined by clarity about our
sanctions goals and effectiveness of
sanctions is determined by
professionalism of sanctions policies
this Council and this commission have
lost sight of the main
priorities our priority is to prevent
Russian government and Russian
Machinery from their ability to continue
financing this genocidal War the goal of
sanctions is not Collective punishment
of Putin's opponents in the
EU the interpretation of sanctions by
the commission just recently According
to which Russian dissidents cannot bring
to the EU their own personal items
shampoo soap those items from Russia is
frankly an embarrassment and self-
ridiculing of our sanction instrument of
one of the most important instruments of
our foreign policy cars with Russian
plates should not be allowed in the
streets of the EU come on listen to that
are those our priorities at the same
time while EU custom officers were
hunting down Russian dissidents and
their personal cars we have heard about
lifting sanctions from Key actors of the
media landscape in Russia based
apparently on two articles in the media
is that professionalism that we want in
our sanction policies we hear reports
about sanctions lists that are created
based on Wikipedia articles is that the
professionalism that we have we still do
not have a clear understanding of how
sanctions are imposed lifted and
implemented dear commissioner dear
Council we must increase pressure we
must enact more sanctions and our
colleagues were right about that we must
close the loopholes but please do it
with a clear view of helping Ukraine
through restricting Russian State and do
this by driving a clear transparent and
professional
strategy thank
you thank you very much Anna figa is
next president Minister commissioner
600 days after the outbreak of fullscale
invasion by Russia of
Ukraine we still discuss how to curb the
the power of Russia to to
perpetrate atrocities war crimes uh
genocide no question sanctions regime is
unprecedented and very
important yet it is neither sufficient
nor uh
consequent we have to broaden it and
many items possible to take were already
indicated I would add to this
diamonds uh once more Rose atom
broadening
individual
sanctions uh and I would add also
sanctioning countries that allow so much
circumvention of sanctions by Russia and
here indicate necessity to BR mini
sanctions imposed in July on
bellarus that
is lukashenka is an accomplice of of
Russia and his regime should be punished
as well thank you
our next speaker is Mr Ty
marani do you remember the first months
following the outbreak of the war in
Ukraine M's ministers and members of the
European Coalition said that we would
bring Russia to its knees thanks to
sanctions would send Russia back to
Stone Age but in fact it's inflation
which is now making Mars of our our
families not to
mention energy costs so we're preparing
another package of of
sanctions even though 8,000 people
already subject to them even Mr Bell had
to admit in March that we were coming up
to the limits of what we could do by
fanatically sticking to these
sanctions everywhere we we're losing out
in in uh Asia and Africa and South
America
now as Mr kabil has pointed out we're
we're still buying two billion euros
worth of energy from Russia every month
and
um like America's our nuclears it also
depends on them so all we're doing is
worrying our few remaining
friends thank you m mes
please a year ago half the German people
taught the EU sanctions hurt Germany
more than Russia this sentiment can only
to be stronger now as Russia's economy
overtook Germany's in August the Russian
sanctions triggered persistent inflation
across the EU higher interest rates a
fall in real wages for workers a cost of
living crisis and a cost of energy
crisis climate goals were trashed as EU
countries fired up Coal Power stations
German's economy entered recession 742
billion euros have been spent on energy
subsidies creating unprecedented Market
fragmentation as rich more subsidy
capable countries draw investment away
from others the NATO proxy war has seen
Europe sacrificed for us interests
European industry has the pleasure of
paying multiples more for us LG than
their competitors in the US the
sanctions have backfired and no one
empowers admitt it what's worse we're
about to put the final l in the coffin
as we gear up to cut off China and D
risk because the US told us to do so in
all this one thing is certainly clear
the EU is the opposite of American
tocy the floor now goes to Milan
urri thank you very much if we want to
talk about the effectiveness of
sanctions we need to say very clear in
Parliament here that the energy
sanctions against Russia are not
working they are harming Europe Europe
more than
Russia
and those who are imposing them are
responsible for Price hikes and
inflation
and another Fiasco Fiasco is the price
limit on Russian
oil when agreement was reached for a
price cap of $60 for a barrel of Russian
y
oil yesterday there was a 7
price
and these sanctions are supposed to
weaken
Russia and help Ukraine but that hasn't
happened therefore these sanctions need
to be stopped thank
you the next speaker is Mr radislav
Sikorski Mr President Comm
ladies and gentlemen uh thank you for
the briefing on the state and impact of
sanctions I fully support the uh
Financial measures uh the um measures to
sty the Russian war effort and measures
to tighten up the effectiveness of
sanctions uh I'd like to focus just on
one aspect of them the Personnel
sanctions a patriarch kill in my view
should also be sanctioned just because
he's a Rel religious figure doesn't give
him uh the right to call for hatred we
sanction various mad mullers we should s
sanction him as well then there is Mr
vasili nebenzia the Russian Ambassador
at the uh United Nations who of course
enjoys diplomatic immunity in the United
States but not here I think it's an
important uh message to send to Russian
diplomats that justifying a um criminal
war of aggression and war crimes may not
pass and finally a real Viper Mr Sergei
kaganov who has been advocating the use
of nukes against Ukraine and against us
he may not have personally harmed
anybody but Julius strier at um at the
nurburg trial also didn't harm anybody
we need to uh send a message here as
well if you behave like a Musik rather
than a gentleman you do not belong in
the gentleman's club thank you very
much
than thank you the next speaker is
Kathleen F brmt Mr President Mr
commissioner as you mentioned since
February 2022 the EU has an
unprecedented sanction pack package in
place against Russia and these sanctions
they mean to change Russia's behavior
and end the war by undermining Russia
economy and although there is a effect
of course but we continue to see that
the Russian economy is not hit as hard
as you would have expected our sanctions
are not as effective as we thought they
would be and first of all and you
mentioned them yourself there's
circumvention in place a lot of products
on the sanction list still go to Russia
and into the Russian war economy so we
need to step up our diplomatic efforts
but also pressure towards these
countries neighboring countries allies
that uh circumvent but also EU companies
that keep exporting these products but
we also need to see how to strengthen
the sanctions when the Russian Goods
that the EU countries still import
represent a value that is multiple times
higher than the support we give to
Ukraine You can conclude we need to do
more and that brings me to the
diamonds there are still not included in
the sanction list and I do not
understand that we still allow Russian
diamonds to be sold in the EU we need to
tell that as soon as
possible thank
you
next thank you the next speak
is thank you president
colleagues it's been 11 months
now and in spite of all of this
the with the sanctions and everything
money has been flowing into
Russia and is every Euro has been used
for Destruction we can see how uh
transport tanks uh everything is
carrying on as usual and those working
in the diamond uh trade continue uh
working with Russian Diamond so the
question is what do we do in the first
eight months
exper exports from Germany um to kistan
increased by 14 14 fold it's absolutely
absurd so what do we do that we've got
the question of development and
cooperation we have to put a stop to
this suspend all this type of
cooperation with states that will look
for Loop Poes to these sanctions we need
to uh however take action now Market
gorova next speaker is Mara
gorova brushing of the obvious tax
Havens and post Soviet Mafia states
there is a massive elephant in the room
China Putin and c will meet in Beijing
today to celebrate many things besides
the belt and Road anniversary they will
undoubtedly toast to successful negation
of our anti-war sanction
total trade between China and Russia hit
a new record high in 2022 up to 30%
China might have single-handedly
neutralized many of our sanctions by
keeping Putin's Petro economy aoat and
the war in Ukraine going China replaces
suppliers of Western electronic and
Engineering equipment Beijing has also
helped Russia circumvent the Swift
sanctions by facilitating more and more
trade with Yan it is evident that while
we attempt to slow down and stop Putin's
mass murder campaign in Ukraine China
does everything short of direct weapon
ship shipments to help Russia my
question to colleagues from Council and
commission is you know full well that
China's involvement has been discussed
in the 11th sanction package focus on
circumvention and you know full well
that your institutions took China out of
its cope how many more pointless
sanction packages are you planning to
pass then while the elephant in the room
remains remains unaddressed also maybe
you can pass on the message to Hungarian
uh Council officials and they could tell
us whether Mr orban's and hungary's
position is now prop Putin as he's not
only blocked another help to Ukraine but
is also the only EU leader present in
Beijing today thank
you Mr Isa chety the floor is
yours
dear president dear Minister dear
commissioner I do think that many of us
agree on those sanctions but I'm a
historian by profession and I'd rather
we
did talk about the
future and the past because many of our
European politicians did prefer to turn
a blind eye to the Russian imperialism
so let us think about the past as well
when talking about this 12th package of
the sanctions we should try and close
the loopholes which were partly
intentionally created
previously because some member states
did get derogations and exceptions and
for that they agreed to vote in favor of
the sanctions Belgium and Italy are such
examples I'm trying to be frank
here we should be
unambiguous when it comes to the
following thing in the west we still
have companies that uh collaborate work
together with Russia and earn a lot of
money from
this uh and we are at least indirectly
tolerating this so this is a paradox on
the one hand we are imposing this these
sanctions on Russia and rightly so on
the other hand we do nothing when faced
with the fact that our companies
especially from Western
Europe uh keep earning money huge money
from the activities in Russia that
should not be allowed okay Mr Pao thank
you Mr Pao Bor has the
floor thank you
president this is a
ba in the context of a conflict people
are
suffering so generating disputes are not
helpful why haven't we leared from what
happened with sanctions in 2014 when the
way they were
evaded thanks to oil exports did despite
the F prices imposed by the European
Union in
G7 so many people are helping Russia
trade with China has
tripled turkey's exports have gone up
90% to Russia so that's the context
we've seen Third Country
operators buying from Europe and and
reselling in
Russia in Spring of last year our first
package had a a tough impact undoubtedly
but since then the rubble has
recovered in R up now obviously the
European Union's ability to influence on
International matters
limited let's start thinking about the
price being paid by European business
for all this Mr Nikolai vson thank you
Mr Nikolai vson EU sanctions on Russia
been effective no not as much as they
could have been special economic
interests have protected different
sectors from sanctions from luxury
handbags exports to Imports of caviar
there's always been a bad excuse the
shipping and banking sectors were
protected even Russian blood diamonds
may only be covered by sanctions from
next year maybe not to speak of how the
turkey's president erdogan is
undermining the sanctions by allowing
Russian Goods to grow through turkey
into to EU and then there are fossil
fuels since the fullscale invasion of
Ukraine EU has paid the Putin regime
more than 165 billion e for fossil fuel
Imports alone money that Putin has used
for the war how many bombs has he bought
for those billions we can do better
let us strengthen solidarity with
Ukraine let us strengthen the
sanctions thank you very much our next
speaker is Miss Clara
Bonos thank you
president loopholes in Russian stions
are yet another byproduct of the you
double standards and lack of Spain just
three examples the illegal issuance of
golden Vis visas to Russian investors
continues in Spain exemptions to Hungary
are granted as a response to Orban
blackmail and sanctions with close ties
to Russia have given aeran the resources
for an ethnic cleansing of the Armenians
in noro kabak while the world is not
even looking double standards may seem a
in shortcut to further EU interest but
they reveal weakness decadence and
Corruption double standards undermine
our credibility and influence as
International actors no wonder that Mr
borell needs to pathetically beg for
recognition from the International
Community when there is a major crisis
if Europe seeks to lead a rulle based
International order and a Humane and
prosperous way of life our strength lies
in our principles I hope it's not too
late to remember that thank
you our next
speaker is
Madame thank you president
commissioner despite the import bands on
crude oil and derivatives we know that
the European Union is still one of the
largest clients for fossil fuels from
Russia the point is that in some member
states first of all although they're in
favor of sanctions they've actually
increased the Imports so much so that
over the first half of
2023 LNG exports from Russia to the
European Union have been the highest of
of the last three years the situation
requires us to
analyze where there are loopholes and
and Emissions that mean the sanctions
not being as effective as they should be
first of all shouldn't we be banning
ban of Russian fossil fuels through
European
economic
Waters we we can't
have
chippers
taking these fossil fuels through our
Waters we must extend the the the
sanctions to to
fertilizers and above all the European
commission should have
centralized stepped up oversight to
enhance the effectiveness of the
sanction regime the floor is
yours thank you Mr President despite the
horrible atrocities happening now in the
Middle East we cannot and must not turn
our attention from ongoing Russian
aggression in Ukraine which entered its
600 and first day we need to continue
pressuring Russia by all means possible
we should also continue with further
measures on bellarus the Kremlin puppet
regime whom we must also keep
accountable sanctions are taking place
in Comm economically challenging times
when our citizens are increasingly an
anxious but we have to keep them going
as Justified response to brutal
aggression sanctions do work but the
efficiency of sanctions needs to be
strengthened including through a shared
approach with our allies there are still
too many loopholes that need to be
addressed particularly recording fossil
fuels energy Imports through third
countries and price caps finally I share
The View with many others that Russian
frozen assets of today can be used to
rebuild Ukraine of tomorrow thank
you for
Dev
so hild vman has the floor thank you
president
commissioner this is our 11th sanctions
package well it's good that we're
adopting sanctions but 11 packages
clearly shows that we haven't been
strong
enough not all the individuals on the
Nali list are on our sanctions
list Russia is still getting around
sanctions through third countries and
Russia is still earning billi I by
exporting oil and gas even to European
countries the sanctions are working but
commissioner they're not working the way
we wanted them to work the Russian war
machine is still working full out and
Putin is still in the subtle colleagues
we have
to raise our game we knew which
countries are helping Russia get around
the sanctions so let's tackle those
countries the capital of Russian Elites
is still spread right over Europe
Europe follow Alexander D Crow's example
use those assets to build up
Ukraine colleagues only if the European
Union works together as one strong block
will we be able to hit Putin thank
you thank
you the floor goes to
Via president commissioner colleagues
Putin the Chinese and their proxies
claim that sanctions do not work yet
Putin also keeps calling for an end to
sanctions that means that sanctions work
and that they hit where it hurts the
most right in Russia's War chest need
more evidence the rubble has repeatedly
broken the 100 cent Mark while Russia's
Central Bank has once again hiked
interest rates to
133% even according to Russian data
Russian's GDP shrunk by over 2% in 2022
instead of of the expected 4% growth
this is a 6% loss in 2021 foreigners
invested 40 billions in Russia a year
later the FDI fall to almost minus 20
billion the G7 oil cap effectively kept
Russian oil well below the market price
thus reducing Russian revenues without
creating oil shortage Russia's budget
deficit widened to 30 billions in July
skilled Russian labor is leaving the
sinking Russian assets are still frozen
colleagues it is clear that Putin has
dragged his country into a bloody
pointless and expensive War Russia is
doomed to fail just because sanctions
work does not mean that they cannot work
even better we should Expose and punish
sanctions evasions targeting the war and
ablers must continue lowering the oil
cap and countering the Russian Shadow
tanker Fleet is the right way to go the
sooner Ukraine wins the sooner the
sanctions will be lifted thanks a
lot thank
you thank you floor goes to Mr
touch thank you president
commissioner we all agree very much I
think there's very broad consensus in
this house that we need these
sanctions we must avoid loopholes and
work rounds we must step up the
sanctions and and until Russia
yields and we must provide resources to
the ukrainians to allow them to recover
their territory there's been a lot of
talk about Orban and
China as
purchases of Russian Goods but here I'd
like to mention the current presidency
the country which has bought the most
oil from Russia in August was
Spain after
China 20% goes to China and 8% going
thly to Spain
now after all this rhetoric let's get
down to bras tax Spain during the course
of its president's office isn't giving
much of an
example there was
now talk of solidarity with Hamas and
and now it's breaking records on um oil
purchases from
Russia next is gar
Beck the thank you president EU
sanctions against Russia should take
effect and be painful
yes we're talking about more than just
Russia but the EU is actually continuing
to import uh gas at high prices via
aaban so it's basically circumventing
its own sanctions
and what about bulag gas which got 400
million and we're talking about a
country that H was involved in antitrust
cases back in
[Music]
and they are allowed to um deliver
Russian gas now by
derogation so keeping mum about all of
this uh all of these going on is not uh
in Conformity with our sanctions policy
now we're talking
about prosperity in Europe and that's
the whole reason why we were set up in
the first place so let's uh take
action next speaker Kina
K thank you very much uh president
commissioner it's been more a year and a
half since the European Union imposed
comprehensive sanctions on the Russian
Federation following the invasion of
Ukraine because of these F these
sanctions Europe is going through an
energy crisis inflation is rising record
levels many households in Europe have
seen their living standards fall energy
companies have been able to enjoy record
profits Energy prices are considerably
cheaper than they were last year
a
few we thought we it said that Russia
would fall to its knees in a couple of
weeks and but things are going through
third countries and Europe is constantly
therefore acquiring Russian
Goods the only people whose lives are
made more difficult by the sanctions are
civilians there is no
doubt that the sanctions are not an
effective solution the only solution is
is dialogue for the war in Ukraine if
the EU wants to end the
war and doesn't want to just crap crap
the whip on its own SS it needs to use
his influence to have a peaceful end to
the
fighting good colleagues I think we can
all agree that the aggression Russian
aggression against Ukraine is unaccept
unacceptable however the sanctions have
not brought about the solution in fact
what we're seeing is Europe is paying a
higher price than the aggressor and the
price that Europe is paying sounds the
death now for the economy and our
competitiveness with new dependence with
soaring Energy prices inflation and uh
disruption to supply chains the impact
assessment was only at EU level not for
individual member states so the
commission does not want to face facts
the commission says that the negative
impact on Europe is minimal and Russia
is lying in ruins it says that the
Russian economy shrank by 2.1% last year
but it doesn't talk about the fact that
this year the Russian economy will
increase by 2.2% while the Eurozone
economy is stagnating of course Russia
is effective but it's still doing
business just not with us and the war
has not
ended the aim of the sanctions was to
wipe out Russian Revenue meanwhile the
amount of LNG imported into the EU from
Russia has increased by almost 40% over
the last 6 months several member states
are importing more oil we need to change
course immediately thank you don't go
Andre Andre you have the
Flor thank you president
commissioner colleagues the sanctions
against Russia and the fight against spy
networks in Europe um are at different
levels in different me States we need um
to do our best in order to stem the
financial inflow into Russia in order
to lessen its capacity to lead the this
War uh there are certain
problems
with avoiding
sanctions thanks to other countries the
aggressor whose bombs have destroyed so
many hospitals
schools and infrastructure has to pay
for their reconstruction that is why we
need to find the legal base and use the
frozen assets of Russia in order to
rebuild
Ukraine Mrs sha has the
floor thank
you now we decided on sanctions against
Russia but the war is still
ongoing does this mean that the
sanctions aren't affective no no way
we're seeing destructions bulldozers
going in overnight destroying houses
um this is part of an overall
package you knock you
Hammer you think nothing's going on but
it is important it is we're fighting
against a threat to our own security and
this Hammer at the end of the day will
finally get through to the foundations
and we will weaken Russia as a result of
the sections we haven't got there
yet but let's keep up the pressure we
have to keep up the sanctions hit harder
and
harder we have to
believe that it will be effective
eventually it's important for our
security for Ukraine's security so let's
keep up the effort we have to carry on
thank you very much uh
president colleagues
Russia is does not want to stop the evil
which it with which it threatens the
very existence of Ukraine in the west
the EU must remain United in its
resistance and it's each member states
Duty we need to increase pressure on
Russia and we need to weaken Russian's
power
the EU must also tighten its stance
towards third countries that support
Russia's aggression against Ukraine in
one way or another this requires even
more effective sanctions we need to stop
sanctions from being
circumvented especially when it comes to
blocking roots for oil gas and
Technology we need
to really prevent the evasion of
sanctions Russia is is clearly using
hunger as a weapon to destabilize the
entire world food system the EU
therefore needs to ensure that grain
from Ukraine can reach markets this is
for the sake of Ukraine and the rest of
the world we need uh assistance with
arms as well as economic and political
assistance until Ukraine
wins thank
you
sanctions are effective when they're new
the vital part of Europe's response to
Russian
aggression this
package is supposed to
weaken Putin's regime but third
countries get around it with shameful
science from the European member states
third of EU member states are
still exporting Goods to Russia that are
directly used to wage war the sanctions
being discussed with the
council now must ensure the sanction
regime is effective and avoid anyone
eving it in the future we have to bring
an end to the way
unscrupulous
profiteering has got around the regime
we need to
protect civil populations in countries
in Conflict so humanitarian players must
be Exempted and international law upheld
thank
you Alexandra
vondra thank you Alexandra vondra you
have the floor we have agreed and we
have implemented 11 sets of the
sanctions around uh against Russia and
by far it's it's a big
success I do not remember anything
similar in the last
decades however it still have the
loopholes and we need to fix the loop
holes and one of the largest loophole is
Iran Iran which is providing the
equipment to Putin including the drones
and other high
technology and Iran which has also its
hidden hand behind what's happened in
Israel a week ago so ladies and
gentlemen one of the most important
thing to fill the loophole is to stop
Iran it's to sanction Iran please let's
move
ahead thank you Yak thank you very much
Mr Yak Madison
please thank you very much uh what's the
aim of the sanctions from the GetGo it
was uh to uh stop the Russian war
machine to deprive them of their funds
and we wanted the regular Russian to
feel the pain of uh of of this War uh
but what's happened we buy more LG Than
Before the War uh more than two billion
euros goes to Russia every month for its
oil and uh every day we see that we have
large trucks going to Russian markets
through Eastern European countries uh
and many political leaders in Europe
have have had to do with the Russian
business such as the Estonian prime
minister for example through her husband
uh which is very regrettable but no war
has been won uh with sanctions before we
feel that if uh the Russian citizen uh
suffers they will rise up but no the
Russian citizen is happy to live in dump
they will suffer they will not rise up
so this war can only be one with tanks
with uh with guns this is the only way
to win the war thank you love kakos
cluse sanctions against Russia to stop
the war in
Ukraine EU citizens are not interested
in the Russian GDP and whether it fell
by one or 2% what do the citizens of the
EU care
about was the war stopped by the
sanctions and how does it affect our
lives a year of sanctions have not only
failed to stop the war but we are
witnessing a new Russian offensive these
days the living standard of EU citizens
in most countries has fallen by 20 to
30%
any person with at least a little bit of
intelligence can see that sanctions
cannot stop the war
however the sanctions are destroying the
living standard of EU Citizens first of
[Music]
all what do we care thank
youas Mr Rio teras
please thank you Mr Vice President dear
colleagues from the very outset of
Russian aggression against neighboring
Ukraine the EU has posed numerous
sanctions on Putin's regime and
Russian's economic interests with 11
packages we have tried to cut Russia
from the markets who have made an effort
to stop uh trading different types of
strategic Goods with the aggressor San
sanctions have real influence only if
they are followed
universally they are part of the largest
strategic effort to force Russia out of
Ukraine unfortunately there's still too
many l holes
and different ways to circum uh
circumvent the post sanctions it's our
task to make sure everyone and everyone
follows the same line and I would like
to turn to European companies and
businesses please stop doing business
with Russia it's immoral to do BR
business with aggressor thank you very
much Slava
Ukraine
next the next speaker is Mr Lopez
agilar feeling president car thank you
very much Mr caras commissioner Reyers
and the Spanish
presidency the if only the Europe could
be as United on migration as it has been
on the in the war by Russia Russia
against
Ukraine the packages
there've been various packages of
measures there've been humanitarian ones
with the temporary
package we had the energy ones and also
the Diplomatic
ones the with the within the GH and the
council there but we've seen 11
sanctions packages in war lasting more
than two years we need to focus on
correct
implementation to
ensure that there is impact for the
sanctions and we shouldn't be buying R
Russian gas via India or via
Kazakhstan there are two pending
decisions firstly we need to ensure that
the confiscation of Russian assets and
goods can be used to fund the
Reconstruction of Ukraine and there's
also one of the most harmed sectors such
as the port sector and the transport
sector as well we need to focus on that
Madame charova
daa Mr President Mr commissioner Mr
Minister 11 sanctions packages have been
adopted they have been adopted to punish
the Russian regime for their war crimes
and to stop the money behind it but what
is the
reality the reality is that trade that
helps the regime to fund this war is
still going on you can see it in the
images of band Goods still on sale in
Moscow and Beyond in Russia it is no
secret that countries like China
Kazakhstan or turkey are being used to
bypass the
sanctions the European Union as a whole
must step up its efforts in enforcement
even further we must seek a solution at
European level we must equally question
our trading agreement with any country
that knowingly allows itself to be a
Transit point for goods going to Russia
such Nations do not Merit our good
relations those that feed this regime
should be shame Slava
Ukraine thank you very much Miss Pata
gempa you have the flo you have the
floor dear president dear commissioner
600 days of the brutal war of
aggression Putin thought it would all be
over in two days but Poland and the
whole of Europe and the US have
expressed its solidarity with Ukraine
Kev has been saved our economy is in
Dire Straits but we need to hold on we
cannot do trade with Russia we need to
continue this solidarity we cannot
negotiate with Putin that regime should
be
vanquished the sanctions are effective
the Russian economy is shrinking we need
to close the loopholes because every
week unfortunately the Russian airplanes
are bringing diamonds to anwp Russian
trains are bringing fertilizers to
Germany and Belgium we need to put an
end to this and the European commission
should also look into what German
companies are doing in Central Asia
there has been a surprising increase in
German exports to those uh countries has
the sanction not being
bypassed thank you Mr Bernard simok you
have the
floor
president thank you president we wanted
to bring Russia to its needs via these s
these sanctions so they could um not
Finance the W but the NG LNG Imports are
record levels and then oil is being and
gas is being imported via third
countries like India we are paying more
and more and once again Russia is going
to increase its
profits has this changed the uh course
of the war in Ukraine in a positive
manner no not at
all the focus on delivery of weapons has
actually cost the lives of tens of
thousands of ukrainians and Russians and
the negotiating position position of
Ukraine has also been weakened
significantly the sanctions have failed
we uh CA correction is
overdue and need to repair northstream 2
and then boost our economy once
again the only way we can end this will
be via negotiations thank
you our next speaker is Franchesca
Donato thank you
president the motive of sanctions on
Russians was to reign in the Russian
government and force it to withdraw from
Ukrainian territory more than a year and
a half following the start of the war in
Ukraine Russia is still there and it's
made difficult progress the Russian
economy is healthier than the European
economy which has suffered
from Europe's sanctions against Russia
which produced a serious energy crisis
and unprecedented
inflation
spiral the sanctions against Russia have
been a complete
Fiasco it would be
better to recognize there's a political
challenge continuing with this system is
going to inail never higher price for us
our citizens and our
businesses if we don't want Russia to
win the war in Ukraine we we must ensure
negotiations into
swiftly there have to be negotiations on
a truce which will save thousands of
ukrainians
lives and fend off the risk of total
defeat for Ukraine it's better to lose
on a small scale than uh face complete
disaster s canet you have the floor
president commissioner Minister
colleagues Russia is planning to
increase its military budget for 2024 by
nearly
70% the sanctions are working but we
have to plug the gaps through which
Russia is continuing to export energy
resources earning 690 million euro a day
unfortunately the European Union is one
of Russia's largest clients for energy
resources adding to Russia's budget to
the tune of two billion EUR every month
EU and member
State sanctions have to be made more
effective so as to reduce Russia's
income from energy
resources
and then we have to cut
the the seeding price from 60 to 30 us
per barrel we we have to stop um LG
imports from Russia and stop third
countries uh getting around this
by exporting Russian oil to us lastly we
was we we must reduce the the sales
servicing and insurance of European
tanks if they're being used to transport
um Russian
oil
mer thank you commissioner colleagues
we're not going to to get anywhere like
this the commission I know the European
commission has done its best but the
problem is the member states the problem
is
Belgium refuses a diamond embargo the
problem is that France won't go against
the nuclear issue so we have lots of
gaps and it's because of the interests
defended by member states of the
European Union we all had hopes that the
general interest of Europe which is to
destroy Putin's regime was going to
overcome these particular interests but
no Imports of LNG are B beating all
records we haven't taken any real
sanctions against those states that are
circumventing our sanctions against
Putin's regime so if we carry on like
this we're just going to weaken the
impact of our sanctions and allow Putin
to carry on with this criminal war of
aggression not just against Ukraine but
against all of Europeans architecture of
security so we have to take action now
we have to confiscate and freeze Russian
Assets in Europe now this is time to
take action be consistent and be
effective in the way we deal with
Vladimir
Putin the next speaker is Neil
TOs
so we need to have sanctions
but we need to have this in
place if Russia continues to attack and
is a threat for our society we need to
continue with these
measures in Finland GE
geopolitics is an island these these
measures have a of huge importance for
us
therefore so we need to have um we need
to have proper
coordination har binsky you have the
floor thank you sir
thank you now ladies and
gentlemen we really need
to take stock of the situation and you
know is were sanctions an
issue were they going to ensure price
stability were they going to take
effect uh you know we've been saying
let's start the sanctions now I've been
saying the opposite and unfortunately I
was right 11 packages of sanctions
against Russian have been imposed Russia
and the situation is what we have things
have got worse you just take a look at
the inflation increase we have
everything you know it's linked to the
poverty levels in Europe everything uh
the business being carried on by the
US uh so convention via China and So
What by Russia and the situation overall
is you know couldn't be more absurd
so we need to work on people coming to
the table to find peace we need to
stabilize things so that we can put a
stop to all this this dying Ian
Stefan Mr Ivan stepanek you have the
floor
thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen European sanctions make
sense our bilateral trade has fallen
below 2% and imports have fallen from
99.6% to 1.7% and or exports to just
under
half and because of the
sanctions people s uh say that um the um
the economy has not been
affected so who asking that who they why
they weapons from a country like North
Korea if we want to weaken the aggressor
we should apply these sanctions in a
consistent Manner and expand them to in
to include diamonds for example
and it's important to ensure we monitor
compliance with these uh sanctions in
order to recognize circumvention at an
early
stage we should not allow the money to
um reach the Kremlin and I will give the
floor to shando Rai
please thank you very much Madame
President
colleagues in February 2022 Russia
attacked Ukraine and Putin's aim was to
overtake Ukraine within a couple of
months but we can now see that Russia
cannot win this war therefore
Europe and um and the rest of the world
to stand on y Ukraine's
side and thanks to the eu's decisions we
have stopped Russia
Army to replace its lost weapons and
access modern weapons unfortunately
Hungary has serious experience of what
Russian occupation looks like
and Victor Orban is
therefore looking to and he's looking to
get closer to Putin and this is
unforgivable we need to maintain
Europe's Freedom peace and security we
need to continue this work and we need
to work together to do so thank you very
much thank you very much and I will give
the floor to Sophia infeld
please thank you Madame chair um
colleagues uh I hear the uh Putin
friends from the left and right extremes
of this chamber argue against sanctions
uh in great consensus invoking the
economic cost to European citizens but
they should tell the full story the cost
of war is infinitely higher both
materially and morally and the cynical
reality is that despite the sanctions
trade continues and we see Russians Rich
Russians living holidaying conducting
their business freely in Europe the EU
law criminalizing the violation of
sanctions will help tackle the uneven
and weak enforcement by the member
states and yes more Harmon ation and
strict enforcement are a key priority
for parliament of course that means that
some countries will have to change their
practices but the whole point of an EU
law is to eliminate backd doors and
Forum Shopping making the sanctions work
however is more important than Petty
power struggles between National
governments and the EU as a raor I'm
determined to conclude the file by
December at the latest and I count on
the cooperation and the flexibility of
of the C the council and member states
thank
you thank you very much and uh our next
speaker is Francisco Jose
Milan graas thank you very much Madame
President the Russian economy last year
um suffered the effects of uh the
sanctions because of negative economic
growth but we could see economic growth
of 2.3% by the end of this year and next
year according to forecast the figures
will also be positive the reality is
that the Russian economy is not
suffering as much as we had
hoped and sanction the um High
representative said these sanctions are
a slow acting poison but are they
actually effective this is a legitimate
question first of all it does the
commission
know if there is step up measures to mon
monitor the compliance with the
sanctions and implementation of the
sanctions and secondly are we trying to
reduce our energy uh we're trying to
reduce our energy dependence but there
are many member states still buying lots
of LNG from Russia and then what about
third
countries so we these These are helping
Russia to evade the sanctions and
hopefully if we look at these issues we
can see some results thank you uh thank
you very much and I will give the floor
to Dima
ker sanctions perhaps have weakened the
economy of Russia but when we talk about
the
objectives uh in order to put a stop to
the war we have failed uh we can see
stability is still fine in Russia
and sanctions against Russian Imports
have been circumvented by a number of
states and going back to November last
year we're back to the level we were
although we had initial uh progress
we're going back we've gone back to the
initial uh
levels such things as micro chips or
drones being sanctioned two-thirds of
the components in the ammunition on the
front use microchips from produced by
the US olig arks with hundreds of
millions of Euros in accounts in
Switzerland have not been had their
assets Frozen so how can we you know we
have to work on these areas if we're
going to be more effective with our
sanctions we need negotiations about a
uh about a truth and to put an end to
the atrocities and
War thank you very much dear colleagues
dear commissioner we have a reacted
against the atrocity of Russia and we
have shown solidarity for Ukraine we
have had Financial measures sanctions
bans on importing Energy Products and
repower EU will be with repow euu will
be totally independent in the energy
sector from Russia but we need to accept
that some of our sanctions have had
limited impact and take action now and
further strengthen in the measures and
we need also new measures in the energy
sector we need to remain firmly
dedicated to upholding Ukraine's
Independence territorial in terms of
energy Unity we need to further support
the provision of military financial and
humanitarian Aid to Ukraine including
the energy equipment that would help to
resist and stop the ongoing attacks and
aggression we need to strengthen the
alignment of efforts across Coalition
countries as well as mechanisms and
measures to enhance the transpar Arcy of
transactions not involving EU shipping
service providers develop additional
administrative capacities and
restrictions on Russian LNG and LPG
thank you so
much thank you so much uh and our next
speaker is LC
please I welcome the fact that we are
going to have new sanctions against
Russia closing our ports for Putin's
ships freezing the assets of the Russian
oligarchs great but can we make it more
painful yes we can but there is someone
who is pressing hard on the breaks I.E
Victor Orban who kept blocking 500
million euro of EU assistance to Ukraine
he blocked the Embargo on oil and he
yield the power of
veto let us deprive Orban of this
possibility to block everything article
7 should be triggered great news from
Poland we will no longer have Budapest
in waro on the 15th of October the
Polish people have voted friends of
Putin's friends have lost power the
toxic Alliance of moravy and Orban is
coming to an end it's coming to an end
thanks to the opposition and the strong
civil uh Society the populists have been
defeated the fifth biggest country in
the EU is back let us build stronger
Europe together thank you very much uh
and now I give the floor to sunana
glak thank you
chair dear colleagues manipulation and
disinformation is very dangerous as we
have heard here
today the bottom line is that the
sanctions were partially effective
however in spite of the sanctions Russia
is still earning money and financing the
war it's time to open our eyes and say
what's really going on what countries
are circumventing the uh sanctions the
sanctions are a symbol but also a
practical measure trying to stop uh the
aggression on a sovereign state like
many of my colleagues I am in favor of
seeing what we can do next it's true
that uh Russian finances have been
affected especially limiting the price
of oil against import but we have to see
what more we can do we have to persist
in Military and financial aid to Ukraine
and while we are considering the
financial implications we have to be
even more decisive because history will
record our solidarity and our will to
use all the tools at our dispos proposal
to create peace on our territories thank
Youk you uh and I give the floor to
tyen please thank you president dear
commissioner dear colleagues Council
finding Unity on sanctions among 27
member states it's not easy in the past
19 months we managed to adopt 11
unprecedented sanction packages against
Russia an accomplishment but it's not
enough first we are too slow the smaller
steps we take the more time Putin and
his oligarch friends get to adapt they
work their way around banss on Tech
goods and oil exports we should be ahead
of them in adapting ourselves member
states have to stop the shameful
exchange of interests when negotiating a
package at the expense of our
Effectiveness if sanctions provide a
disproportionate disadvantage to member
states help them second we need to
enforce our sanctions if not we are
creat creating the loopholes to violate
restrictive measures ourselves and thank
you commissioner for your personal
commitment to adopt also antiv violation
uh legislation we cannot have more Forum
Shopping by and impunity for Russian
criminals we have to fix this thank
you thank you very much and now I give
the floor to Ludas
mailis
please
thank you very much Madame chair
commissioner colleagues the in Autumn
2021 we discussed sanctions against
Russia while it was amassing 100,000
troops around Ukraine's borders and we
were very brave at that
time we said if it if it is if it
attacks we will also cut Russia off from
the Swift system and I said myself that
this was quite uh a mild uh request
the braver ones saw Russia economy R
Russia's economy
ruined and in the meantime we've imposed
sanctions packages indeed bans on our
own businesses Russia is arming itself
further so how long will the um internal
Market be open to Russians we need to
have uh a more courageous
scenario
president commissioner uh sanctions on
Russia show us what we can do when we
work together EU money should not fund
Putin's illegal war in Ukraine Europe is
a trading superpower and EU sanctions
should show Putin the consequences of
breaching international law the figures
lay out the extent of our actions 11
sanctioned passages in under two years
1,800 individuals and entities targeted
including Russia's leaders
21.5 billion of assets Frozen 91.2
billion of Russian import sanctions
including in Tech transportation and
luxury goods our focus should not only
be on more sanctions but also in
ensuring the effectiveness of those we
already have Russia has of course sought
to disguise its exports by selling them
through third countries colleagues we
need clear rules and sanctions and
consequences of a failure for example by
large companies to implement sanctions
and of course country we should
countries we should not accept Russian
products passed off under the radar of a
different country Russia must continue
to pay the highest economic cost for
what it is doing in Ukraine let's make
sure that they do thank
you thank you very much uh we come to
our catdi procedure and the first
Speaker I'd wish to give the floor is
Shan Kelly
please
good I think the important point now
especially from the commission's point
of view is not to be telling
us about the sanctions we've had and how
the German economy is
retracting but tell us where and how the
sanctions are being aided and it's quite
obvious that it's
widespread even member states who have
signed up to sanctions
are importing Russian products from
third countries who are directly
importing from Russia that's not good
enough and that has to be stopped the
same with companies who are not abiding
by sanctions and I think we need a
discussion on the sanctions that are
there how they are working and what the
commission are going to do immediately
to ensure that those who are trying to
evide them are going to be stopped then
we can talk about another package of
sanctions and I think that's the key
comeon thank you very much Mr Kelly our
next speaker uh is gorgio
Kos thank you
president uh s sanctions are important
and rather effective but they produce
results mainly in the medium and long
term they are not going to solve the
problem of Russia's war against Ukraine
Russia is in a position and will remain
so to finance its aggressive war first
we created a huge energy dependency we
decreased this dependency but Russia was
able to cover its financial needs in
2022 and
2023 second there has been a global
shift in favor of major economies like
China and India that have increased
their collaboration with Russia third
the Russian private sector ctor the
oligarchs was able to react rather
effectively to the challenge of
sanctions sanctions are important and
should become more effective but the
only way to move forward decisively is
by helping Ukraine to win the war and
not just survive the Russian aggression
thank
you thank you very much uh and I'll give
the floor to CLA Daly
please thank you president those who
told us 11 times that sanctions would
bring Russia to its knees there were a
necessary gesture of solidarity with you
Ukraine part of the toolbox to end the
war are still clinging to the lunacy
that maybe the next round will work
we've heard colleagues say ah well Shas
we know they never fully work or well we
need to add a load of named people to
the list we need to include diamonds we
need to tighten up beyond the Wikileaks
link we need to blame China all of it
nonsense the truth is sanctions don't
work everyone the US the countries which
contain a majority of the world's
population continue to trade with Russia
our LNG imports from Russia increased
40% since the war the commissioner says
the Russian economy is less efficient it
has higher costs and it's a war economy
I don't know if that's true but I do
know that the European Union economy
which he was very silent about has
certainly got higher costs is less
efficient and commissioner Breton tells
us it's a war economy and with the
amount of money we're shoveling into
arms it seems like it the Euro zone is
in recession the cost of living crisis
is hitting Ordinary People are paying
while Ordinary People in Ukraine pay
with their lives we need peace and
diplomacy and an end to this
nonsense thank you very much and now I
give the floor for one minute to Costas
maddz please
Costas
thank you mad
president those of us who seek the for
the effectiveness of the EU sanctions on
Russia we also agree that the problem is
loopholes and practices that circumvent
them some blame it on China on Iran on
Kazakhstan but these are not EU members
neither members of NATO and certainly
they are not our strategic partners
turkey is in accession process a NATO
member and some still call it a
strategic partner the figures after the
war are astonishing turkey's exports to
Russia increased by
50% and Russia's exports to Turkey by
almost
200% while the EU citizens absorb huge
costs rightly so due to sanctions and a
final Point while all this is going on
Russia and Turkey are still in strategic
cooperation to develop the auu nuclear
power plant with significant risks for
the EU citizens especially those in the
Mediterranean so the problem is not just
loopholes it's double
standards thank you very much uh with
this uh we close our debate of the
speakers but not of course with
listening carefully to what commissioner
reinders will tell us please
commissioner thank you madam president
honorable members let me reassure you
once again that the sanctions are
working obviously they're not our sole
means to bring the war to an end but
sanctions are working against Russia
just as they
worked in other situations but we must
you're quite
right redouble our efforts first of all
I've taken due note of the list of
proposals whereby we could extend the
various sanction regimes as you propose
them as you'll be aware in the
commission we're working together with
the member
states to move forward in unanimity in
the European Union both in our dealings
with Russia and Belarus as some of us
recalled it's our daily task to ensure
that we can cover the broadest possible
range of activities that we want to Res
restrict or
prevent on Russia and B's part and we've
done this in the 11 packages up until
now on the basis of unanimity you will
have
understood that above and beyond
defining sanctions something which is no
doubt at least as important is to ensure
the effective implementation of those
sanctions and to fight any means of
evading them let's take the example of
asset
freezes we've Frozen the assets of um
more than 1500 individuals and 270
bodies which means 27 million worth of
assets including of alarts have been
fren and over 200 billion assets have
been frozen across the European
Union in terms of assets the authorities
particularly the reserves of the Russian
Central Bank what we're working on now
together with
you is finding ways of ensuring we can
fight the way the asset freezing regime
is being evaded and actually take a step
further and confiscates said
assets that's why we need to complete
our current work in the trialogue on the
proposal to amend the directive on
sanctions evasion this will allow us to
to open court procedures
and not just freeze assets but
confiscate them should anyone seek to
evade the sanction regime those assets
could then be used to help rebuild
Ukraine and provide compensation for the
damage suffered by a number of victims
so we're continuing to work on the
sanctions
evasion evasion of any types of
sanctions the UTS or exports of of goods
as you've mentioned as I pointed out
earlier on we've appointed a special
boy who's in touch with a number of
governments and
bodies to ensure we we can pursue this
fight against evasion in conjunction
with the member states and our
International Partners I've also taken
due note of a number of your comments
regarding individual
cases particularly Russian dissidents
obviously we've looked into those
individual cases as mentioned but I must
remind you that in the context of all
our sanctions regimes we also need to
respect the rule of law we need to
provide proper legal motivation for the
decisions we take that applies in
particular to the lists of individuals
subject to sanctions whose assets who
wish to
freeze cases have already been referred
to the European court of
justice if some keep stressing the
negative decisions we've had to take on
certain we we have also had a number of
positive decisions and I'd like to to
stress the professionalism of those
seeking to to get these sanctions
regimes
working asset freezing is particularly
important part of that but thank you for
taking part in this debate which shows
that there's still work to be done in
completing our list of sanctions but
above all there's a day-to-day task to
be done to ensure that the sanctions we
have are enforced effectively and that
we're able effectively to to fight any
attempts to evade the regime
commissioner
uh and now uh finally the state
Secretary for European Affairs for the
council Rios Pasqual Navaro
please
much thank you very much Madame
President
commissioner ladies and
gentlemen I'd like to reiterate the fact
that the
EU adopted the most ambitious uh
packages package of sanctions to deal
with Russia and the EU continues to work
will continue to work on more sanctions
if necessary it's also prepared to
maintain this sanctions policy as long
as it is
necessary as the commission has said
sanctions are one tool in the European
Union to support
Ukraine but there are also other tools
involved in this support for
Ukraine I'd like to highlight that
sanctions are designed to prevent
Russia from carrying out its war of
aggression against Ukraine they have all
been adopted unanimously in the
council they can cause effects in the
European Union of
course and as several of you have
mentioned we need to work to mitigate
some of those effects within the EU but
in any case the European Union is
convinced that the effect is much
greater in
Russia when it comes to the possibility
of new initiatives as the that that the
commission mentioned the council will of
course analyze these
closely so to conclude thank you very
much for your contributions to this
debate I am sure that if we maintain our
Unity we'll be able to exert pressure on
Russia in the future by adopting new
sanctions where
necessary until there is uh way for a
fair peace to ensure the sovereignty ter
territorial sovereignty of Ukraine thank
you very
much thank you very much uh with these
words uh the debate is closed and the
vote will be held at the next part
session this leads us uh to the next
item on the agenda the commission
statement on the International Day for
the eradication of poverty uh and in
this regard I would like to inform the
members that there will be a